[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas noches
bueno como me presentaron yo soy me ría
hey
y vengo a contarles un poquito qué pasa
cuando los hijos se van de casa
en mi caso en nuestro caso en realidad
tuvimos que pasar por esto cuatro veces
cada vez que cada uno de los chicos
partió de casa
y me voy a centrar en el día en que me
tocó despedirlo a ezequiel
el más chico de nuestros hijos
había decidido irse a los ángeles
hacer una experiencia de trabajo y de
estudio en casa de una familia que lo
iba a recibir allí
y en los ángeles es lejos claro pero
nosotros viviendo en el lugar en que
vivimos
a donde se vayan nuestros hijos siempre
es lejos siempre lejos
y una vez que ellos toman esa decisión y
tienen esa determinación de irse hacemos
muy bien los padres en acompañarlos
el día que yo lo acompañe a ezequiel a
la terminal de ómnibus
llevaba su valija con todas sus cosas
pero fundamentalmente iban todos sus
sueños todos sus anhelos
todos sus proyectos
y que puede hacer uno frente a eso más
que desearle que encuentren su camino
que se encuentre y que empiece
verdaderamente a recorrer su vida nos
abrazamos en un abrazo
realmente donde no nos dijimos nada pero
los dos sabíamos que nos estábamos
diciendo todos
bueno fue quedar ahí
viendo cómo se alejaba y se empequeñecía
y se ómnibus
con la mano en alto y volví a casa
y en el sillón me desplomé
y lloré por supuesto que lloré me
gustaría saber si acá
los que me están escuchando habrán
madres que han pasado por eso
seguramente
que levanten la mano yo no las estoy
viendo pero seguramente hayan muchas
manos levantadas
y lo que sintieron y díganme si no
comparten conmigo ese momento
johnny todo lo que había contenido esos
días previos a la partida de ezequiel
pero bueno
la vida seguía y así seguí yendo al
trabajo todos los días a la tarde cuando
volvía me recibía la casa vacía sin un
ruido sin esa compañía que es tan
necesaria que sabemos que nosotros
tenemos
volvía al famoso nido vacío
los pichones no estaban habían volado
y a diferencia
de lo que hacen las aves después que los
pichones vuelan
y esa mamá no se queda llorando en el
nido sino que ella también vuela y un
poco
bueno decidí que yo tenía que salir
también y encontrar mi vida que hice
empecé a caminar empecé a caminar que
era algo que a mí me gustaba mucho lo
hacía todas las tardes oa veces a la
mañana en fin pero
y encontré en eso de las caminatas una
forma de llenar mi vida porque bueno eso
se sumó que así excursiones conocí a
lugares y vamos a hacerlos cercanos a es
que el lugar es lindísimo que tenemos
por aquí como podía hacer el cerro la
torta como podía ser el cocinero como
podría ser barril en fin todo
de alguna forma esto a mí me significaba
planificar
organizar cosas iba armando mi vida
un día podría decirles cualquier día
yo estaba
en la cocina vamos a suponer que estaba
preparando un tuco y llega a mi marido y
me dice
sabéis que me encantaría que te subas
al velero conmigo ese era un sueño que
él tenía
un proyecto largamente acariciado donde
yo sentía que no tenía nada que hacer en
realidad porque para mí
mientras más firme tengo el piso mejor
y bueno
se imaginen subirse a un velero es
exactamente todo lo contrario
es un movimiento continuo y además para
que se dé una idea no sabía nadar
sin embargo y es aquí donde yo les
quería decir que está bueno estar
atentos a las sorpresas que nos puede
deparar la vida yo me subí a ese velero
venciendo absolutamente todos los miedos
absolutamente todos los miedos
lo que me enseñó eso les puedo asegurar
que fue una de las experiencias más
maravillosas que yo tuve en mi vida
porque más allá de las inclemencias que
se pueden encontrar arriba de un velero
tuve que acostumbrarme a moverme en
espacios reducidos
[Música]
y hacer guardias nocturnas por ejemplo
acostumbrarme a esa soledad inmensa que
puede ser el mar porque terminamos
cruzando el océano con una de nuestras
hijas embarazadas o sea que arriba el
velero íbamos cuatro en esa oportunidad
en
también el velero a mí me enseñó lo
importante que es mantener la calma
cuando todo alrededor es un caos
en el año 2009
[Música]
hice algo que siempre me había gustado
escribir y publiqué un libro que se
llama cuentos para mis nietos donde cada
uno de los nietos es protagonista de su
historia
en el 2013 con una amiga decidimos hacer
el camino de santiago
e hicimos el camino más largo el camino
francés y esta vez probamos la
resistencia qué bueno que a veces
desconocemos que tiene nuestro cuerpo
y analizamos los pirineos bueno un viaje
de peregrinos interesante espiritual
lindísimo llegamos a santiago de
compostela inolvidable en el 2017
escribí el libro de la patagonia extensa
al mar infinito
donde narró el momento en que me vengo a
vivir a la patagonia a un campo cercano
a la zona de gobernador costa
en un lugar inhóspito en medio de la
nada allí nacieron nuestros cuatro hijos
e
y creo que me recibí de patagónica no sé
bueno y también en ese libro escribo
esta la aventura que fue navegar con ese
velero
finalmente en febrero del año pasado en
el 2020 me invitaron a un viaje por el
sur de india estuve un mes
y bueno me encantó conocer ese otro
mundo que también existe donde la
espiritualidad forma parte de lo
cotidiano me gustó muchísimo muchísimo
también a lo largo de los años me amigué
y aprendí la tecnología la incorporé
en fin trato de no quedarme afuera de
esto me parece que es importante lo
mismo que los idiomas estando en grecia
aprendí griego porque es un idioma que
me encanta y trato de profundizar el
inglés en la medida que puedo aunque me
cuesta yo les voy a dejar una reflexión
y ustedes pensarán y verán a qué
conclusión llegan pero qué hubiera
pasado aquel día en que lo despedí a
ezequiel si yo me hubiera quedado
sentada llorando en aquel sillón
mirando fotos viejas esperando que los
hijos me llamen que me cuenten sus cosas
y en definitiva hubiera vivido a través
de ellos
nada más muchas gracias